you've probably heard of people having a
stroke and you're probably
familiar with with the notion that has
something to do with the brain and you'd
be right in particular it's a it's a
rapid loss of brain function because of
something strange happening in with the
blood flow to the brain and let me show
you that in a little bit more detail and
to do that let's think about the two
major types of stroke there's the
ischemic strokes
ischemic there are the ischemic strokes
ischemic stroke and the other type of
stroke is hemorrhagic and these can also
be kind of sub-categorized but i won't
go into all of the details there
hemorrhagic
hemorrhagic stroke and if i really just
define ischemia and hemorrhaging to you
i think you'll have an idea of how these
strokes are different and how they
interrupt the blood flow to different
parts of the brain you know from the
videos on stenosis and ischemia and the
videos on heart attacks and ischemia is
a lack of blood flow to certain to
certain body tissues so an ischemic
stroke is actually very very similar to
what we saw in a heart attack except
it's not occurring in a coronary blood
vessel it's occurring in a blood vessel
in the brain so let me draw that right
over here let's say that this is a blood
vessel in the brain
this right here is a blood vessel in the
brain
and let's say the blood is flowing in
that direction this is an artery
and so you can imagine that maybe there
is a blood clot that forms in some part
of the brain let me do the blood clot in
magenta this blood clot might form
because no that's not magenta the blood
clot might form because maybe there's a
plaque there maybe the plaque got
ruptured either way this blood clot is
restricting the flow of blood and we
know that this blood clot we can call
this a thrombus
thrombus
or we could say that thrombosis has
occurred over here either way the blood
flow is restricted and and the the brain
tissue that's further downstream is not
going to get its oxygen and it might die
it might experience infarction
and that's why ischemic strokes are also
sometimes called cerebral infarctions
cerebral
cerebral infarctions these are all very
fancy words but i think hopefully
they're becoming a little bit more
common in our vocabulary they keep
showing up over and over again and i
also want to be clear escape most
strokes are actually ischemic strokes
the the numbers i looked up they say 87
percent 87
of strokes are ischemic now the other
type of way that you could have ischemia
in one of these blood vessels and is
completely analogous to what we saw in
in the heart when we had heart attacks
is you could have thrombosis or you
could also have an embolism whenever
they have the whenever someone says
thrombosis or thrombus or thrombi
they're talking about blood clots
whenever someone talks about an embolus
or emboli or embolism they're talking
about something moving through the blood
that eventually blocks a blood vessel so
you can actually have a thromboembolism
you can actually have
you can actually have a blood clot that
gets broken off so instead of so you
could actually so let me let me ignore
this for now or let me let me paint over
it a little bit so that this isn't the
main cause of blockage but you could
actually have a blood clot that breaks
off
becomes a
becomes an embolus
it becomes an embolus and since it's an
endless due to a blood clot you call it
thrombi thromboembolis i always have
trouble saying all of these words and
eventually it blocks it blocks a part of
it blocks an artery right over here so
this right here is an embolism
embolism but either way you're blocking
the blood flow further down the brain it
could cause infarction that brain tissue
will die and whatever that brain tissue
did for
for mental function or whatever is going
to make it very hard for this person
who's experiencing the stroke to do
those things now it's not always
noticeable that's called called a silent
stroke but but damage is occurring the
person experiencing the stroke and i'm
not a doctor so take all of this with a
grain of salt
the person experiencing the stroke could
be anywhere from well one they might not
even notice it even though damage is
occurring they might have a headache or
it might be more severe they might
actually not be able to properly move a
side of their body or side of their face
or properly be able to speak so it
really depends on what part of the brain
is being damaged but in either of these
situations an ischemic stroke is caused
by some type of restriction or blockage
that causes things downstream to not get
proper oxygen and then so you can
imagine cells over here aren't going to
get their oxygen and that they might
actually die a hemorrhagic stroke to
hemorrhage literally means to bleed it's
literally just a fancy word for bleeding
and so in a hemorrhagic stroke you have
a situation
where a blood vessel can actually break
where you have a blood vessel i'm trying
to draw the same blood vessel where it
actually breaks and we can we'll talk
more in the future of why a blood vessel
might break strongly related to high
blood pressure and other risk factors
don't want to get into that right now
but you can imagine if a blood vessel
breaks you have all this blood spewing
into a brain into the brain kind of an
uncontrolled way so let's say this
little diagram i do here let's do that's
part that part of the brain if you have
a hemorrhagic stroke you have all this
blood that's flowing into the brain and
you can imagine all that uncontrolled
blood will mess up that part of the
brain it'll it'll cause those neurons
and brain tissue to malfunction and
maybe even cause some of it to die and
it would also cause the blood flow
further downstream to be impaired so
it'll also the stuff downstream aren't
going to get the blood they need because
all of the blood is being released
everywhere else and since 87 of strokes
are ischemic strokes the remainder are
hemorrhagic so this is the remaining
the remaining i should say the remaining
of strokes